non mais c'est vrai qu'avant je veux
c'est beaucoup j'étais je sais beaucoup
gtpob plus grand changement qu'est ce
qui a changé et et pmp pour vous dans
votre vie de tous les jours tout alors
dans mes beinheim vous étiez connu avant
donc arrête win un messie mais non mais
franchement ça a changé énormément ce
que moi les gens qui me suivaient avait
avait mon âge
maintenant il ya aussi des deals qui me
suivent et qui sont hyper sympa les gens
qui vous suivent leur crache donc
apparemment l'attention attentivement
mois ils vont pas assez vite en fait non
mais d'accord oui mais voilà donc ça m'a
donné une bouffée d'air frais bush
julien combes et sa carrière solo vous
êtes une star
vous plaisantez alors on va prendre de
l'essence il est avec vous cyril hanouna
bio au restaurant il est où cyril
hanouna
on va en vacances il va venir si rien
n'assure pas que vous étiez sur nrj 12
des tags stars dont il que non mais ce
que j'ai amené à l'émission phare de
l'émission je peux vous dire moi oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mon chéri j'ai trouvé une famille j'ai
trouvé l'amour
j'ai trouvé le sourire s'est trouvé la
vie à l'asse peut vous dire vous avez
trouvé surtout la connerie choix en ce
moment vous l'avez bien trouver gens
alors celui pour qui sa plus jolie
soumissionnaires faire ça c'est cabot
avant tout mon boss chopin inexco figaro
je me rappelle que j'avais fait nintendo
avec une pesée de la peine
il voulait être sur tous les dossiers et
chopper personnes de plus il est sûr
qu'un dossier sur plus chaud qu ils
furent toujours pas mais au moins elle
connaît son nom précise michel non mais
c'est vrai qu'avant je veux c'est
beaucoup j'étais je me sais beaucoup
j'ai des pommes mais le plus grand
changement et maintenant c'est vrai que
j'arrive beaucoup plus à pécho du coup
matonge à venger quand je tends trouver
une resté sept ans disant lesquels
attendent on trouve une c'est vrai que
sept minutes c'est bien sûr gilbert
d'être alors vous pousse à changer parce
que vous verrez arriver vous étiez
personnes connues mais pas comme ça
surtout avant je faisais des demandes en
mariage en me disais non de grâce à tous
pas comme quoi la moyen rien
automne et oui bon voilà oui non ça et
n'a changé énormément de choses
physiquement la vie personnelle
professionnelle voilà oui c'est une
aventure extraordinaire
voilà bah oui ça change le quotidien
voilà moi je suis très ancré dans le
quotidien
ça change la vie quotidienne on va
souffler sur ce créneau j'ai pris
beaucoup avant le succès rimbaud c'est
une vraie s'il vous plaît il s'est
embelli on va pas quand même si c'est la
vie il avait lourd ibos
même moi d'abord je vous apprends jeu
plus près et ça honnêtement ça me fait
plaisir parce que rtl vous voyez de plus
loin brigitte jeanne gère plus de
copains beaucoup plus jeunes y en a
beaucoup qui cherchent des grand'mères
vous savez on vient de se rendre compte
c'est un barbecue aussi c'est vrai que
je voulais pas venir dans cette émission
je pouvais pas en bien quelques-uns qui
ça le plus au bois y avait un orage il
j'étais totalement réfractaire et non
plus et en fait
premièrement j'ai ce qui est curieux
c'est que les gens m'ont découvert alors
ça fait quand même quelques années que
je faisais de la télévision ils m'ont
trouvé sympathique enfin on va dire mais
et surtout c'est vrai que ça j'ai
commencé chez drucker on avait une
quotidienne et c'était un plaisir
d'aller bosser parce que tous les jours
on se marrait et ont bossé et moi j'ai
redécouvert après 1 an 1/2 retrouver le
boulot tous les jours avec bonheur avec
des gens qu'on aime et qui sont je vous
dis franchement de vrais gentils
honnêtement j'avais des tonnes d'à
priori et je pensais que tout ça était
fake mais tous été fabriqués parfois on
s'engueule c'est vrai mais j'ai trouvé
des gens qui ont vraiment beaucoup
d'amour à donner
et j'ai trouvé un petit frérot que je
pensais pas être exempts voilà un hameau
j'arrive à me faire chialer
[Musique]